- Hi there.
I'm Seth Juarez and I've got Nebojsa Jojic,
Principal Researcher and Lucas Joppa,
Chief Environmental Scientist
at Microsoft with me today
to discuss an exciting initiative
that applies AI
to sustainability issues
called AI for Earth.
Welcome my friends.
- Thank you.
- Welcome.
- Awesome.
Let's start first with, what is AI for Earth?
- Yeah, well so the world's
got some pretty pressing problems.
I think that's no secret.
In my opinion, one of the biggest ones
is the increasing impact
of human activity
on earth's natural systems.
And that really begs the question
of how we're going to use
all of this incredible technology
and artificial intelligence
that we're creating
to help societies
thrive in an increasingly
resource-constrained world.
Microsoft's been deeply committed to environmental
sustainability for a long time,
and that's why last week
we announced the public availability
of this new program,
AI for Earth
which is really dedicated
to deploying the full scale
of Microsoft's AI services
and technologies
and research investments
to organizations
on the front lines
of environmental sustainability.
Nonprofits, academics and government entities,
to help them solve environmental problems faster.
- That's awesome that we have a Chief
Environmental Scientists on staff
at Microsoft,
first of all.
What are the key areas for AI for Earth?
- So AI for Earth as a program focuses on climate,
agriculture, water and biodiversity conservation.
The way the program's actually
set up is with three pillars.
We're looking to provide access
to organizations to all of Microsoft's AI technologies.
We're also looking
to provide education, so that those organizations
actually can take
advantage of the services
that we're making available.
And then finally, we're also offering
the opportunity to work directly with us
as Microsoft employees
to deliver some showcase projects.
And so the demo that we're going
to be showing today
is actually an example
with some partners
where we bring all of that together;
both access education
and collaboration.
- Awesome.
SO AI for Earth is using AI
to help with environmental
challenges that happen.
All right, so let's look at this demo
that you are talking about.
Can we do that?
- Yeah, we definitely can.
- Awesome.
- So this demo is all about you taking
a deep learning approach to a pretty common task,
which is trying to
build land cover maps.
So land cover maps, so just classifying earth's surface
into things like forests, fields, water,
impervious surfaces
like roads and houses,
so trying to go from those
high resolution images
that people are so accustomed
to looking at today
and actually turning those
into labeled data points.
We've been working with two
really important partners for this project.
One is a small organization on the east coast
called the Chesapeake Conservancy,
and another is a large software provider
that is a major player
in the GIS geographic
information systems
software world, Esri.
- Of course.
- And what we've been
doing there is Chesapeake Conservancy,
with their partners,
spent a lot of time
and a lot of effort
putting together a data set
that's really kind of the first
of its kind of high resolution,
1 meter resolution,
data set of the Chesapeake
watershed on the East Coast.
And the reason that that's so important
is because for the first time,
it provides us as AI
researchers the opportunity
to have an incredible
training data set
for a deep learning approach.
Because the AI applications
that we're building are so data hungry,
and in environmental applications
we're often times data poor.
So this gives us an opportunity
to drive a deep learning approach
to create hopefully
a first of its kind.
A high resolution land cover map
for all of the United States.
- So before we get to the demo,
why would a land cover map be important?
Because like I'm thinking AI for Earth,
we're going to program robots to pick up trash.
But that's clearly not
what we're talking about here.
Why would this, why does this particular
application help when it comes to environment?
- Yes, so for instance,
land cover mapping in particular,
it is the first thing
that you need to know
before you can start
making appropriate environmental policy
and managing our natural resources.
- Oh, I see.
- So you need to be able
to look down and understand
what is where, how much is there
and how fast is it changing.
Can you imagine trying to ask
a financial services manager
to manage an investment portfolio
without letting them understand
what's in their portfolio,
what trades have been made,
or anything like that?
- That makes sense.
Yeah, because I used to live in Las Vegas,
and Lake Mead has gone down tons.
And if you don't have a land cover map
that shows you the differential,
you're not going to know
what's actually happening.
- That's right.
- All right, let's see what you've got, my friend.
- So let's go here.
So what I want to show you first was set things
in context for you a little bit.
So what you're looking at here,
this is Esri software called ArcGIS
Pro that we're running
this application in.
And what you're looking at here
is across the United States,
a one meter resolution open
government data set.
So this is produced by the U.S.
government through a program called
the National Agricultural Imaging Service or program.
Sorry, we're getting ourselves
back up to speed here.
Perfect, yeah, there we go.
All right.
- So tell us what we're looking at here.
Some people didn't get to see it.
- Right.
So, what people are looking at here
is a map of imagery across the United States.
It's collected and made available
for free by the U.S.
government.
- OK.
- And then over here on the East Coast,
you can see where there's a bunch of
different colors of greens and blues.
That's a map that this organization,
Chesapeake Conservancy,
with a bunch of their partners in the region,
put together to convert that imagery
into actually labeled data.
So as we zoom in here you can see
that they've taken this imagery here
and converted it into roads
and houses, fields and forests,
so that the computer
can actually understand
what that imagery represents, right.
- And it uses vector data on top of an existing map.
- That's right.
- Awesome.
Now I'm starting to get it, understand it.
Like I said, I had this dumb idea
of robots picking up trash.
But here we're actually looking
at some vector data over real...
But I'm noticing that the little green part
is actually really small, right?
Because I looked at the United States and I saw like,
hey, there's a big United States and there is this.
This is the only data we have, right?
- That's right.
And what's actually available
for all of the United States
right now is at 30-meter resolution,
and it's five years old.
- That's not helpful.
So if you're trying to manage lands
in real time, it's almost impossible at the moment
to deal with resolution
that encompasses roads and houses
and many other things
all within one pixel,
and is over five years old.
- So where's the, like I understand the mapping.
Where is the machine learning part of it
that we want to talk about?
- So what we did was we used this dataset
as training data for an algorithm
that would then be able to be
used across the United States.
So while this map is hugely useful in the
Chesapeake Watershed over on the East Coast,
it's not all that useful
everywhere else in the U.S.
So how do we create a single algorithm
that's capable of, of course,
working where it was born and bred,
but also capable of classifying land cover
in Oakland County, Michigan, for instance.
And I'll show you an example of this, how it all works.
- Let's do it.
And if I pause with questions,
just humor me a little bit, OK?
- Please, no please do.
So I just wanted to show you the data set here.
But what I'm going to show next is
a web application that we built.
So after training our model, we were able
to just output that model file
and host it in Azure and Microsoft Cloud.
That is something that can be queried
with any imagery from anywhere.
And so this is that same location
in the Chesapeake watershed,
and you can see that just
with a click of a button,
when I click here this rectangle
will become highlighted.
The service will segment that image out,
send it off to our model file,
and in real time send back a result
that has the land cover classification.
So you can see in just a few seconds
in that same region where it was trained,
we're able to classify land cover
almost instantaneously.
And as you can see, quite accurately.
We can also go up here and you can look
at how we're doing with houses, for instance.
And you'll see that there's two boxes
that I'm showing here.
One is the actual final guess
that the algorithm is making.
I think that's a road, a house, a forest, or a field.
And then the one above it is actually a
mixture of probabilities from the model.
And that's really helpful
from a research perspective,
because I know we have
a bit of a research audience
mixed in with everybody watching today.
Because that really lets us understand
how the algorithm is thinking,
and thus what we might need to do
to start to improve it.
What additional training data
sets do we need to show it.
- Can we go back to the picture?
Because this is pretty impressive.
You're saying that you've taken
this data, and there you go.
You can see it now.
You've taken the actual data, you've trained it
so that now the machine
can automatically create
the cover for it, essentially.
- That's right.
- And the one on the top is showing the distribution
of where the sort of like the likelihood
of this being like light green,
I guess is like grass.
- It's field, yes.
- So the bottom is what it predicts,
the top is here is how I feel generally about that.
- That's exactly right, because you know,
unless you have a perfect model,
which statistically speaking you kind
of don't want to anyway
for a generality,
there's a non-zero probability of it
being any of these different classes.
- Sure.
- Right?
And so the model has to decide
which is which, ultimately.
And so when you look at it this way, you get to see,
oh well, ultimately in the bottom
it thinks that's forest
and that's field.
But you can see there's a little bit
of hesitancy one way or the other,
and that really is helpful for us
to be able to understand how to make this better.
- Now Nebojsa, you've kind of been sitting here.
But now I want to ask you, how is this done?
What's the AI techniques?
- So this project is actually similar
to the previous segment that you were talking about,
the segmentation project.
- Oh of course, yeah.
- The difference, I guess,
one big difference is that
instead of looking at lots of images
that are segmented into lots of smaller images,
we are looking at one huge image.
This is 10 million kilometers squared.
And as Lucas mentioned, we are trying to classify it
at the resolution of one square meter.
So it's one humongous image
that we're trying to classify,
and what we've been using here
are these convolutional neural
networks which consists
of multiple layers of processing.
Each layer will convolve the image with a bunch
of filters that automatically learn from the data,
and then the output is going
to be processed again.
And we have dozens and dozens
of these filters, of these layers.
And then at the end we have a classification
of each pixel into its corresponding land cover label.
We did have to change the tools that we started with,
and we started with our Kinect toolkit,
which worked fairly well.
But in order to adapt it
to this application,
which hasn't been really used
with this type of tools before,
we had to innovate a little bit
in terms of making the models
more sensitive to shape
rather than color,
because as you can imagine,
when you look one way or the other way,
they can look very dark,
or very greenish or blackish,
or they can even look white
if they are empty, which happens.
- Oh my goodness.
- So to be able to be robust
with all of these things,
we had to change the representational a little bit
to be more relying on shape than color and texture.
We are also looking at all these
things in multiple scales.
And then basically what happens is you
take all the data from Chesapeake Bay,
you fit it into the learning algorithm,
it runs for a few days
and out comes a model file
that Lucas mentioned,
which you can then use to classify things anywhere.
- Now does it generalize pretty well?
Because I'm imagining, like I'm putting it
over like the middle of Nevada,
and is it going to. Tell me about that.
- Yeah, so I'll let Nebojsa speak
to the technical aspects of that.
We can show you one area
where it does generalize,
and then maybe as Nebojsa gives
an example we can show some places.
- Yeah, does it do because we just tested it
on like what we trained it on.
- That's right.
- That's a good indication of kind where
- As you can imagine, in the areas
which look similar to Chesapeake Bay,
it is going to do very well.
- Right.
- And that's probably what we're
going to show now, right?
- Yeah.
So what I'm showing here is a land cover map
in Oakland County, Michigan this time.
- OK.
So we've moved from the East
Coast of the United States to smack in the middle.
- To the middle, yeah, the middle.
- And the reason that
we've moved here is
because this is a county
that have also put together
one-meter resolution land cover map
for their jurisdiction.
- Oh nice.
- But this is
a hugely resource
intensive process for these organizations,
and so they did
this seven years ago.
And that's what you're looking at here.
- So we're looking at, if we can
get that back on the screen,
we're getting the seven-year-old data back here,
this is seven years old.
- That's right.
- OK, cool.
- And this image is a year old.
- OK.
- Of the exact same place.
So you can see that a lot has changed.
- Sure.
- In particular, this intersection has gone
from a T-intersection to a roundabout.
- To a roundabout.
- And of course, this is going on
with housing developments,
road developments,
and many other things.
And so if you're not staying current,
if your algorithm isn't current,
updating you to much more
current information,
you can quickly fall further behind.
So I'll just show, we'll zoom
into that same location.
Sorry.
- So now we're going to
the location in Michigan that has really good data,
but five years ago.
- Yeah.
And which our algorithm has never seen before.
- Of course.
And I'm looking at this,
and it looks a little different.
- Yep.
So we'll click here.
And so it is using the same model
that we generated from the Chesapeake Bay.
- That's right.
- To predict what's going on here.
Like we said, in a place that it's never seen before
and where they have existing land cover maps
but which are now out of date.
And you can see it
with the click of a button,
we were able to update
that old land cover map
almost instantaneously.
Right.
- That's amazing.
- So that's a strong statement
towards transferability,
geographic transferability.
We're still, you know, I'm showing you one place
where it works beautifully.
- Sure.
- There are many places
still where it doesn't
and Nebojsa can
talk a little bit
about how we're moving forward
to tackle that.
Nevada was a great example where our algorithm
currently thinks deserts are forests,
which is, you know, is about as wrong as you can be.
- But this is amazing, though,
because this makes it, you can do, for example,
you can sample areas
that are representative,
small areas that are representative of many
of the areas in the United States,
and then use those models to generalize
over the entire landscape, is that right?
- That's correct.
- That's true.
And in addition, that's why I mentioned
that we are trying to make the models more reliant
on shape rather than color,
so they can generalize better.
So for example, they work in Bellevue where I live,
and don't see the water over my house.
They actually classifying now
well in the Seattle area.
But beyond that, if you want to move
to other sort of labels like swamps
and whatever other people
are interested in,
what different types of fields,
agricultural developments and so on,
then we could benefit
from new types of label data.
But we are trying to build these algorithms
to require as little label data as possible,
so if a user downloads a new class
or wants to correct our map somewhere,
they can maybe work on 100 meters
and that algorithm will then use
that to generalize
over acres in that area.
So the way we are seeing this kind of going forward
is that since we're not always going to be interested
in only in the half-a-dozen classes
that we're looking at right now, but even more,
and we are going
to have to adapt
to different types of landscape,
then we are hoping and we're expecting
actually that as the users
and other people interested in all of this
would work on downloading
that data into the same depot
which you can visualize
with tools like this.
And then everybody's work would then
get amplified by these algorithms,
and would generalize over all the areas.
- That's amazing.
So someone out there is really concerned
about the environment,
and they want to help out,
hey, donate an hour
of your time labeling some map,
that maybe we've never seen.
We suggest, here's 10 that you can work on.
They can set that, upload that,
we retrain the neural network, it gets better,
and then they can upload even more stuff.
- That's exactly right.
That's the real power I think of machine
learning approaches in this space,
is that when people are doing
the hard work, right,
they know that the work they're doing right now
makes their life easier into the future.
And I think that's just so important
because people have become so accustomed
to recreating the wheel over
and over and over again,
every year going through the same steps
to create the same map,
just to see how things have changed.
In this instance, you do a lot of the hard
work up front, as Nebojsa said,
you let that algorithm train
for days and days and days.
And now it's incremental after that, right?
Then it's just little bits of change
can have transformative effects
of the algorithm's accuracy
across large geographic areas.
- And I think the cool thing
is that you can, in theory,
and you tell me if I'm wrong, you can use old data
with old maps to still train good models.
- You can, yes, you can.
- So I mentioned the mock and scale approaches,
so the data, the old data with a 30-meter squared,
could be used to bootstrap
the learning as well.
- I see.
- But our goal is to make
all of that sort of in the background.
So that basically the tool that you're
using which looks like a map,
you're labeling things
or downloading things,
you're making predictions
and so on, the algorithm is in the background,
adapting to everything you're doing
and becoming better over time.
So that really it's about humans
using these things
and communicating amongst themselves
and making decisions
that just over time gets easier and easier
for them as a result
of their previous work.
- So just to finish out,
the time went by really fast.
This is really interesting.
Where is AI for Earth going next?
- As a program, this is the first big year.
We were just launched last week.
We're super excited to be here
at Faculty Summit,
because we're actively looking
for academic collaborations in this space.
This project in particular will be looking
to start to deploy our algorithm
at a national scale,
to be able to figure out
just how accurate are we already
and what research breakthroughs do
we need to make over the next 12 months
to be able to really nail this.
- Awesome.
Well thanks so much for being with us,
Nebojsa and Lucas,
thank you for your demo
and conversation today.
Thanks for your work and thanks
for making the Earth a better place.